my name is branch and I'm a troll  why do I live in a heavily fortified  survival bunker because right outside my  door lurks a nightmare  named poppy poppy is the leader of the  trolls and it's not her fault she's so  insanely happy she just never faced a  real problem until now  cupcake branch we just got attacked by a  Bergen Bergen it took everybody what's  your plan to rescue everyone to make it  home safely so you're going to scrapbook  them to freedom solid Bern branch I got  the Spanish inside my bones  it goes electrically when I turn it on  yeah I got that sunshine in my pocket  you got that good solar my feet feel  that happen  Fadi this mom your shift  just  so just let  okay  may I oh snap  DreamWorks trolls  he and the others to certain death death  death death death death do you think you  can tell us which is the right one you  bet  great no that's all